hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will ihr wisst ja dass ich
zurzeit ein paar prüfungen und zur heute
habe ich mache das zweite staatsexamen
und da habe ich immer lust auf etwas
schokolade und deswegen werde ich wollte
ein richtig leckeres schokoladen dessert
machen was auch richtig toll aussieht
dass ich nicht ein jahr war das sehr
diesem bisher habe ich hier einen
brownie als grund tag habe eine schoko
platte drüber und habe hier eine richtig
leckere warme ganache aus zarter
schokolade und das ganze wird ergänzt
durch ein wald fruchteis das bisher
besteht also aus vier komponenten einmal
der brownie da ist kalt die schokoladen
passe dies auch kalt dann der warme
schokoladenguss also die ware garage und
natürlich das leckere eis und wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie ich dies sehr gemacht
habt dann bleibt jetzt dran und wir
beginnen jetzt mit der schoko decke und
dafür braucht ihr nur zwei zutaten und
zwar habe ich hier zahlt peter kurth
türe
die habe ich klein gehacktes 150 gramm
als ich hab nicht die ganze packung
genommen
ich habe jetzt zeit später verwendet ihr
könnt aber auch voll mit kuvertüre
nehmen
auf jeden fall ist es wichtig dass es
kurzfristig habe die kleinen erwartungen
habt ihr zwei drittel drin
und hier ein drittel also hier sind
jetzt 100 gramm etwa drin und hier etwa
50 gramm
die schokolade umsehen temperiert werden
und hier habe ich drei kleine stückchen
palmen dass ich dieses kokosfett was wir
jetzt gleich dazu benötigen
viele fragen mich immer wieso man keine
normale schokolade verwenden kann
zum schmelzen und zwar ist es so dass
die normale schokolade oftmals andere
bestandteile noch enthält in der
charaktere ist nämlich nur kakaobutter
kakaomasse und zucker mit drin und auch
die emulgatoren also die bindeglieder
damit die verschiedenen teile überhaupt
so als schokolade zusammenbleiben
ihr braucht den hohen fettgehalt
kakaogehalt der fettgehalt ist in der
kubatur viel höher und fett heißt ja
dass es später beim schmelzen flüssig
wird und ihr wollt ja auch die kuvertüre
beim schmelzen flüssig wird die normale
schokolade könnt ihr nicht verwenden
weil sie beim schmelzen gar nicht so
flüssig wird und ihr später gar nicht
damit arbeiten könnt also immer wenn ihr
schokolade schmelzen holt und sie über
etwas trübung geben wollt so überziehen
oder eben jetzt für die schoko platte
müsst ihr immer kuvertüre benutzen wenn
ihr schokolade klein raspeln gold um sie
mit in den teig zu mischen könnte auch
ein formales karate bin ich zeig euch
jetzt wie man die schokolade temperiert
das habe ich zwar schon ein paar mal
gemacht aber jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
für alle und zwar glaubt ihr eine
schüssel und ich machte fernsehen
wasserbad und mach das nicht auf dem
herd weil der herr viel zu heiß wird für
die schokolade
ihr solltet obmanns auf dem herd
schnellsten weil diese schokolade dann
verbrennen kann ich habe zu ihr wasser
ab und gibt da jetzt meine zwei drittel
schokolade mit rein also 100 gramm im
städtchen ins wasserbad und jetzt warten
wir um rühren bis die kuvertüre
geschmolzen ist
da müsst darauf aufpassen dass kein
wasser in die kurve tür hereinkommt und
so kann euch die kuvertüre nicht
anbrennen
weder im topf noch kann da jetzt
kochendes wasser rein kommen
das ist einfach die sicherste methode
und chöre zu schmelzen und auch die
beste methode wenn man nicht gerade ein
professionelles temperiergeräte hat
jetzt die quartiere komplett aufgelöst
und ich nehme sehr aus dem wasserbad
heraus jetzt ist hier nämlich richtig
schön heiß und muss jetzt wieder
runtergekühlt werden und deswegen haben
wir vorhin dieses stück weg gelegt also
50 gramm ein drittel vom ganzen und
geben das jetzt mit dazu die kuvertüre
wieder abzukühlen
jetzt wollen wir so lange bis es sich
wieder aufgelöst hat das dauert jetzt
eine weile aber das ist auch sinn und
zweck davon
manche fragen sich jetzt vielleicht
wieso man das überhaupt macht so
umständlich erst erhitzen dann wieder
abkühlen und zwar aus folgendem grund
wenn ihr mal als quartier verpackungen
anschaut steht das rind dass man die
kuvertüre in warmen wasserbad auflösen
soll und dann die kuvertüre unter
ständigem kühlen auf 30 grad bringt die
optimale temperatur importeure liegt
soweit 35 bis 37 grad
und mal ganz ehrlich da steht ganz
einfach drauf musste das auf 30 grad
abkühlen
aber was sind überhaupt 30 grad ist
kriegt man das thermometer gar nicht hin
deswegen egal welche menge an kuvertüre
ihr habt ihr könnt es immer mit der
methode machen dass ihr zwei drittel vom
ganzen also ihr teilen drei portionen
und zwei drittel davon erhitzt ihr im
wasserbad dann hat so etwa 50 60 grad
schokolade und wenn ihr dann das
restliche drittel schokolade dazu gibt
kühlt das ganze runter auf etwa 30 grad
und gegeben dass jetzt gleich für die
kuvertüre ganz aufgelöst ist noch einmal
ganz kurz ins wasserbad so dass wir etwa
35 bis 37 grad erreichen
und dann können wir die kuvertüre
benutzen und es müsste auf jeden fall
machen ihr könnt sie nicht heiß
verwenden weil ihr dann diesen
grauschleier auf der schokolade bekommt
das kennt ihr bestimmt hatte ich früher
nämlich auch ich wusste dass mit dieser
methode nicht und habe da die schokolade
immer geschmolzen auf dem wasser mal auf
dem herd und hab dann im kühlschrank
wenn die schokolade da drinnen war
diesem grauschleier bekommen die
schokolade glänzt nicht und bleibt doch
einfach nicht formstabil und so
verhindert ihr das eben und können wie
die schokoladen profis eure eigene
schokolade bzw kuvertüre schmerzen aber
irgendwann habe ich auch vor mir mal so
ein temperiergeräte zu besorgen möchte
einfach mal ausprobieren und mal schauen
so funktionieren so die schokolade türe
aufgelöst ich gehe jetzt nach hause für
zehn bis 30 sekunden hier rein und jetzt
kommt dieses paar mit rein das sorgt
dafür dass die kuratoren noch ein
bisschen flexibel bleibt geschmeidig und
gibt dem ganzen auch noch mal einen
schönen klang bei uns hier in
deutschland heißt spanien
ich weiß nicht wie es in österreich oder
in der schweiz ist auf jeden fall ist es
kokosfett palm feld und das gibt's im
kühlregal wahrscheinlich habt ihr
einfach nur in anderen namen bei euch
und jetzt habe ich mir hier aus
vorbereitet und zwar braucht jetzt ein
stück backpapier und ich hab das ganze
auf meinem torten wetter ist ja aus
edelstahl ist richtig schön kalt und
geht da jetzt meine temperierte
schokolade drauf und weiß glatt
streichen
ihr könnt es natürlich auch auf einer
anderen platte machen hauptsache ihr
habt irgendwas damit ihr später dieses
papier eben transportieren könnte sonst
müsste ich sage hier liegen lassen
ich brauche meine arbeitsflächen und
jetzt werde ich das ganze mit einer
palette glatt streichen könnte aber auch
genauso gut mit einem langen messer
machen
jetzt wird es einfach etwas glatt
gestrichen so ein paar millimeter zeigt
das machen lässt nach augenmaß
und jetzt klopft ich das noch ein
bisschen auf die arbeitsfläche damit die
kleinere luftbläschen hier noch
verschwinden
ich stelle meine schokoladen platte kühl
im winter können dass sie gern auf den
balkon und auch mit terrassen stelle
neben sommer würde ich das eher nicht
machen damit sie nicht fest ihr könnt
sie auch in den kühlschrank stellen
aber auf jeden fall müsst ihr aufpassen
dass jetzt nicht ganz fest wird sodass
sie bricht denn wir werden sie gleich
noch ausschneiden und ausstechen und
dafür sollte es noch etwas geschmay
nicht geschmeidig bleiben werde ich den
granit herstellen und ich habe mich
jetzt für den roboter entschieden ihr
könnt natürlich jeden anderen
schokokuchen nehmen jeden den kuchen der
euch am besten schmeckt aber ich wollte
euch alles braun ihre zeit sowieso
zeigen und zeigt euch jetzt hier nochmal
die zutaten
ihr braucht 100 gramm zucker 75 gramm
braunem zucker und falls ihr den ich da
habt könnt ihr auch einfach nur weißen
zucker benutzen und nehmt dann eben 175
gramm
ihr braucht 50 gramm kakaopulver bitte
backkatalog 100 gramm mehl 2 eier und je
nach größe eventuell auch drei also ich
habe hier zwei große eier
falls ihr zu kleine er habe neben dritte
325 gramm schokostreusel oder klein
gehackte schokolade einen halben
teelöffel backpulver eine prise salz und
hier habe ich 90 gramm butter die habe
ich schon bei leichter temperatur in der
mikrowelle zu lassen
das ist heute ganz ohne küchenmaschine
und hans rück gerät machen
ich möchte einfach mal zeigen dass man
auch ohne maschinen ganz tolle sachen
zaubern kann
einige fragen mich erinnerung
wie soll ich ständig küchenmaschinen
benutze und das geschäftskonzept was ihr
ganz gut auch ohne machen könnt ich habe
meinen der mutter mein held flüssige
butter hier rein gegeben
gebt da jetzt noch die eier mit rein bei
den halter sich selbst farbe achten dass
wir nicht heiß ist sonst gerechnet die
eier dann kommt da jetzt sogar mir dazu
den römer da jetzt einfach schön ein
brauner zucker auch wieder zu und jetzt
der rest mit rein also mehl backpulver
und salz back kakao und die schoko raste
und jetzt verrückt es einmal komplett
und das ist übrigens auch das rezept was
ich in meiner backmischung hatte diese
geschenkidee aus dem glas diese brownie
barth mischung des ist dieses rezept nur
habe ich jetzt hier keine liste mit rein
weil jetzt einfach einen glatten teig
möchte ich möchte keine stückchen
mitreden deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
ganz viele stücke genommen und
normalerweise gehört er auf 50 gramm
nüsse mit rein und dann sind es die
perfekte details sollte so aussehen also
ziemlich zähflüssiger fest datei riecht
sehr schokoladig ist sehr schokolade und
natürlich sehr lecker oder teig ist
fertig und jetzt gebt ihr den teil in
einer höheren und ich hoffe auch gut
geworden
eine rochade frau ich war jetzt vor
kurzem auf einer messe auf sogar ganz
großen haushaltes und ja so eine messe
eben für alles und habe mir jetzt auch
mal neue formen bestellt weil ich ja bis
zum ein produkt repertoire erweitern
möchte in meinem shop und die haben
einfach party angesprochen ganz ähnlich
aber deine kommen übrigens auch diese
tanks aber was mir an denen nicht so
ganz gut gefällt dass er nicht aus einem
stück sind ich habe diese blaue in
meinem shop schon die aus einem
stück bestehen und da bleibt eben kein
teig und so dranhängen und hier
wenn man jetzt mehr zeit hätte wird
natürlich die art hängen bleiben aber er
ganz in rosa und ich probiere jetzt
einfach mal und die sachen die probiere
ich jetzt mal aus eine zeit lang und
wenn sie gut sind haben sie einen schock
wenn sie nicht so gut sind dann kriegt
die samira zum spielen oder ihr schenkt
seiner schwiegermutter wird sich frau
installiert die form hat jetzt ein
fetzen
ihr könnt es ganz normal mit butter und
mithin zu machen oder mit einem back
trance break geht einfach schneller
hinterlässt dabei wurden kopf und ich
gebe trotzdem immer auch gerne etwas
mehr noch trüber einfach um
sicherzugehen dass wirklich nichts daran
haften bleibt bei dem formel ist es
nämlich so kann man auch personalisieren
lassen muss also ich könnte jetzt auch
auf die rückseite mein logo drauf
drucken lassen und da bin ich jetzt
gerade dabei und bin schon gespannt wie
sie jetzt aufwachen noch wie sie sind
und ja mal gucken weiß nicht wer könnte
mir einen kommentar zum opfer auch auf
großer steht oder ob ich eher neutral
mit den farben bleiben
den teig ich da rein
übrigens habe ich auf der messe auch
ganz viele verschiedene firmen gesehen
unter anderem auch richten und bei den
reitern dort ich finde das echt cool die
sind jetzt alle innovativ und haben viel
zu bieten die sie aus amerika habe dann
mit ihnen gesprochen so weit es ging auf
englisch und er hat mir mal die kataloge
zeitgründen hat ja immer 3000 produkte
und der katalog für deutschland die
produkte die für deutschland zugelassen
sind sind knapp 8 bis 900 also seht ihr
mal wirklich dass die europäer andere
standards
und die deutschen natürlich und das eben
bei uns nicht alles erlaubt ist wie in
den usa zum glück hab ich da immer weil
ich echt nicht wissen will was dann in
den anderen 2000 produkten drin ist dass
die bei uns überhaupt verboten werden
und da wäre ich jetzt auch andere
produkte testen
vielleicht versteht sich dabei und ja
ich bin echt geradeaus probier phase
ich probiere alles auch mit dem
verteilen von teil geschieht bisschen
schwierig weiter so zähflüssig aber so
sonja braun zähflüssig schokoladig süß
die form hat jetzt so die maße etwa 25
mal 25
das ist die perfekte größe für brownies
und ich kann mir auch ganz gut
vorstellen dass man in dieser frage ganz
lecker dass anja machen kann und ich
habe übrigens von diesem rezept ganz
viele variationen entstand gemacht und
da zeige ich manchmal mit himbeer und
frischkäse und so schnell richtig
gotthold die brownies werden jetzt im
ofen bei 175 grad etwa 30 minuten
gebacken
danach werde ich herausholen ganz kurz
abkühlen lassen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder da beziehe meine
schokolade die es nicht ganz fest falls
ihr euch noch zu fest ist können darüber
gehen und jetzt braucht er der ringe
oder ausstecher in der größe der hat
jetzt mit durchmesser von 8 cm
ich möchte nämlich später dass meine des
rcv 8 cm im durchmesser haben den
kleinen brauche ich jetzt nicht den weg
zur seite
und falls ihr keine aussteller oder hat
das heringer habt können doch einfach
ein glas benutzen wir werden es nämlich
jetzt sowieso mit messer schneiden und
dafür zeige ich euch ist wie ich das
machen und zwar gebe ich jetzt meinen
dass hering einfach da drauf und damit
so ein schöner abschluss ich schneide
ich das eben
und ich zeige ich das jetzt auch einmal
mit glas ich habe jetzt so große latte
macchiato gest ihr könnt natürlich auch
kleinere benutzen dann habt ihr einfach
kleinere bisher war ganz fröhlich und
damit die schokolade richtig schön glatt
noch mal so eine lage backpapier drauf
und dann könne es einfach beschwerlich
legt aber so ein tablett drauf damit es
richtig schön glatt bleibt mein kuchen
gebacken
da hat nur 20 minuten gebraucht letzten
mal 130 dann müsste auf jeden fall mit
stäbchen probe machen also ein
zahnstocher reinstecken und wenn nichts
mehr dran hängt dann ist der kuchen gab
ich werde jetzt gleich so heiß wie er
ist offene abkühlt platte stürze
wunderbar sei auch nichts dran hängen
den werde ich jetzt einmal abdecken und
lass ihn komplett auskühlen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich unter mein brownies
jetzt abgekühlt und werde ich werde
jetzt mit diesem des hering oder mit dem
glas diese kleinen kreise ausschneiden
und spaziert ist jetzt ziemlich weit
außen damit ich so etwa fünf stück
hinbekommen
um im glas geht es natürlich genauso und
die raste die erste seite aber auf essen
oder er benutzt sie krümmels gemacht
sondern macht kate ob strauß oder macht
so eine geschichte daraus also ich komme
für die reste hauptidee und jetzt müsst
ihr die deutschen noch weiter
verarbeiten
dafür braucht sie den ausstieg oder den
kleinsten des hering was ich hatte nie
einen deckel oder irgendwas runde was
eben gut jetzt da reinpasst und zwar
kann man das jetzt hier ausstechen das
klappt jetzt gut
und wie gesagt falls ich hab nehmt euch
eine kleine entdecker und könnt dann
messer schön außen herum weg stellen so
und dann drücke ich das ganz vorsichtig
mit dem daumen durch so dass mir das
äußere nicht kaputt geht
jetzt gehts anrichten wir werden gleich
noch eine schaltstelle aber ich zeige
euch schon mal wie man den kuchen
anrichtet oder anrichten kann
und zwar nehmt ihr jetzt so 1 mittwoch
und platziert ist schön auf dem teller
jetzt könnt euch entscheiden ob jetzt
einen nimmt oder zwei übereinander
ich bin zwei sehen halt besser aus weil
sie schön hoch sind und jetzt gibt da zu
einer show coupe platte die menschen
ganz runter die kommen als oben drauf
für die garage habe ich hier zwar noch
zarter schokolade
die habe ich schon klein gehackt und
habe hier 50 milliliter sahne die habe
ich ein bisschen erwärmt und jetzt werde
ich die schokolade in der mikrowelle
jeweils in 30 sekunden schritten etwas
erhitzen damit sie warm wird können
natürlich auch im wasserbad machen
ich mache jetzt einfach ganz vorsichtig
in der mikrowelle weiß schneller geht
und zeigt euch dann gleich die fertige
show beraten
wer meine garage kennt merkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich dass das ein anderes
verhältnis
ich habe jetzt hier viel mehr schokolade
als sahne deswegen musste ich jetzt auch
die schokolade zuerst schmelzen weil 50
gramm sahne die reichen ja nicht um zwei
monate zu spenden
und das muss so sein weil die garage
zeiss verwendet wird und nicht kalt und
so dickflüssig sei deswegen brauchen wir
viel schokolade und wenig sarah gebe ich
da noch die sache mit dazu wird es ganz
vorsichtig miteinander vermischt zieht
jetzt aus setzt sich das nicht verbinden
aber das verbindet sich gleich die frau
nichts mit der schokolade könnt ihr sehr
gut vorbereiten aber sobald die
kanalstadt gemacht ist muss alles sehr
schnell gehen
ihr könnt ihr übrigens auch gerne mehr
zahle mit rein geben die sonne schön
fließen solle konsistenz dass sie schön
heiß ist und schön flüssig danach gebe
ich einfach nochmal in die mikrowelle
und lass dir nochmal war melden wenn du
jetzt erst den teller fertig servieren
damit die nicht wie schon wieder abkühlt
und zwar gehe ich dann von der kugel eis
mit drauf eigentlich passt ganz
kontrolliere oder so wahllos alles hatte
ich leider nicht da deswegen habe ich
aus meinen tiefkühl früchten kurz selbst
gemachtes eis gemacht gibt da jetzt noch
so eine kugel mit drauf
jetzt muss alles ganz schnell gehen die
schokolade muss jetzt halt sein und
steht danach muss ist schön warm sein
damit gleiche effekt passiert
und wenn ihr dann den kuchen es
schneidet ihr ihn an
und wenn ihr wollt dass da mehr lava
heraus kommt müsste eben mehr ganache
eingeben
ich nehme alles wieder zurück was ich
über das man ihn ausgesagt habe
ich finde special eismassen zu fassen
ist ein wald fruchteis oder so ein punkt
als mit etwas teurer weil es passt
nämlich perfekt zu dem schokoladigen zu
diesem herben und ihr müsst die zahl der
schokolade machen wirklich ich weiß
viele sind kein fan von twitter
aber da ist einfach die beste schokolade
drin viel schokolade und das passt
richtig gut wenn ihr beim zubereiten der
garage probleme damit habe das ihr euch
zu fest ist da gibt einfach ein gutes
stück panin mit rein
das macht ja das ganze wieder flüssiger
weil ein paar weniger fett ist also wenn
euch die sahne nicht ausreicht geht da
ruhig etwas mehr palais mit rein so dass
sie richtig schön flüssig ist sie dafür
nicht zu heiß sein dass die schokolade
gleich durch spricht deswegen sollte
schokolade waren seien aber nicht zu
heiß müsste vielleicht 12 mal
ausprobieren
aber wer nichts mit diesem party macht
klappt es auf jeden fall
ich lass mir dass er noch schmecken das
andere vielleicht auch und dann wünsche
ich euch auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen
ich werde das rezept auf meinem blog
veröffentlichen diesmal auch sehr
pünktlich wenn wir jetzt schon hier
haben das rezept von meinem daumen
kiesweg habe ich mittlerweile auch schon
online
und ich werde euch die fraktionen auch
mal um rechnen
ich habe jetzt eine braune form gemacht
und habe jetzt zwei so doppelte des ems
rausbekommen einen schoko ring habe ich
noch das heißt wenn ihr kleinere
portionen haben wollt also die flacheren
sind es fünf portionen und wenn er die
doppelte menge haben wollt sind sie eben
nur zwei halbe portionen
da schreibe ich euch einfach die menge
hin falls immer wissen wollte wie ich
mein eis selbst mache könnte mir auch
einen kommentator lassen
da schaue ich freue mich über eure
kommentare
wertungen ich freue mich auch über ein
abo und ich freue mich natürlich auch
das nächste mal und wünsche euch noch
einen ganz schönen tag steht einzig die
könnten die ihre eissorte mit ihrem
lippenstift und ihrer schütze abstimmung
mit der küchenmaschine aber ehrlich okay